la crisis de seguridad de política sigue
agudizándose en haití este miércoles el
primer ministro del país caribeño josé
couso anunció su renuncia sin dar
detalles
esta tarde presenté mi renuncia al
presidente de la república joven el mois
ha sido un honor servir a mi país como
primer ministro
agradezco a los miembros de mi gobierno
a los técnicos y a los financieros su
colaboración el presidente yo ven el
mois aceptó su renuncia y aseguró que la
decisión ayudaría a combatir la
inseguridad en el país y a resolver la
crisis política ya que goes no contaba
con el respaldo del parlamento
la renuncia del gobierno que acepte
permitirá abordar el pla grande problema
de la inseguridad y continuar las
discusiones con miras a lograr los
consensos necesarios para la estabilidad
política e institucional de nuestro país
el ministro josep lotes nombrado primer
ministro interino haití se encuentra
sumido en una serie de secuestros
sistemáticos perpetrados por grupos
criminales por lo que muchos ciudadanos
tienen miedo a salir a las calles
durante el primer trimestre de 2020 el
país registró 142 casos de secuestros
casi el triple que los 51 reportados en
el mismo período del año pasado todos
los segmentos de la población están
expuestos a este tipo de sucesos el
último secuestro fue el domingo cuando
retuvieron a 12 personas entre ellas
siete religiosos dos de los cuales son
franceses por lo que la iglesia hizo un
llamado al paro laboral este jueves 15
de abril los raptos indiscriminados han
generado varias protestas de la
población en los últimos meses que
reclama al gobierno que actúe